[Music]
okay welcome guys - I don't even know
what this class is called strategy
strategy session so today I didn't
prepare anything I arrived from London
last night
I'm still pretty jet-lagged it's 7:30
p.m. about here which means it's it's
after midnight in London so that's kind
of the time I feels for me right now so
we're gonna play on the chess I'm gonna
do a live play with commentary I'm gonna
get suggestions from you guys hopefully
this will be interactive in terms of
openings if anyone has a favorite
opening that you want me to play let me
know now anyone have a favorite opening
yeah
Arjun French Queens gambit for whites or
for black for black Queens gambit
declines okay QG d4 black yep the con so
the con for lack okay so French con
viniq you have a favorite opening oh the
colleague ah I've never played that
but maybe we'll try and play it and
favorite opening no okay well since
that's a white opening okay we're white
no one suggested a white opening or in
the play E for first move
well we're playing against the Sicilian
so are there any efore players here yeah
Russel EEMA okay we'll play nine of
three if he plays knight c6 or d6 we'll
play Bishop to b5 so you know this you
know this player I know if this will be
in the video but we're playing Nathan
f31 for who's actually a big follower of
mine
we'll play Russell mo I have not played
this too seriously in a tournament but I
know 94 is not supposed to be the best
move because we can simply take and then
black structure is not the best
I think it just makes sense to Castle
hearing like black black has yet to
touch anything on the kingside and we're
already castled so I think the strategy
here is just to try and open the center
as quickly as possible and he's thinking
which is a good sign it's also a good
sign that if he plays minus six we might
have d5 so it's not entirely clear how
black should develop here in the
meantime we should kind of figure out
okay how to continue for white he plays
a six so I assume Bishop c4 is the best
move and there's actually a funny trap
here let's imagine he plays b5 whites
and move and win material it's a nice
tactic Ashish yeah Bishop f7 king f7
Queen H v g6 Queen D 5 and we attack the
King in the rook on 8 so this is an
important lesson when it's not your move
okay he'd played it we should double
check though I was gonna say when it's
not your move you should always be
thinking about tactics so Bishop take
out 7 King take out seven Queen h5 I
mean he could play okay King f6 Queen at
five mate right so g6 Queens e5 e6 we
just take on AIDS and he just said good
luck in the chat we want to wish him
luck in this position
but he's thinking when there's only one
legal move which you should never do in
Jess if you have one legal move you
should make it and then think the Queen
h5 if King e6 it's made into with Queen
d5 King f6 and Queen at five mates so he
has to play g6 yeah what a sad sad game
he's been waiting for a while like he
challenged me I think twenty minutes ago
as I put another fit where I put a
message on my my discord channel he was
the only one that saw it the Queen d5
okay we're gonna take the rook I don't
think he's a type of player who resigns
too quickly though so we might have to
actually convert the material advantage
but we are up wrap upon and the exchange
and he still has nothing developed
except his king oh but he wants to maybe
trap our queen this is a threat Bishop
a4 queen a7 Bishop c5 this might not be
so easy actually as I I did not
calculate this far and if he's able to
trap our queen that could be that could
be devastating do you have a suggestion
margin before preventing Bishop c5 that
he could take on before yeah Bishop e3
yeah it might be worth like giving away
a pawn or even two pawns to save to
prevent the Queen from getting trapped
yeah before certainly a candidate move
[Music]
yeah what else to consider b5
yeah e5 we would like to like have two
moves in a row but this should be sevens
coming very quickly
I was thinking d3 Bishop e7 Bishop to f4
which actually might work because if he
takes the bishop we take his bishop and
that's a good trade if he plays a five
we just take on e5 so d3 Bishop e7
Bishop f4 if he plays d6 he no longer
has access to c5 for the bishop which I
think and I'm trying to double-check
this but I think that's okay oh you're
saying d3 Bishop d6 but then we can play
e5 and life is good right oh and then oh
you're saying Bishop to c5 first but
then then Queen f3 right okay I'm gonna
play d3
I think assuming this works I think it's
a better move than before so we just
want to continue development sorry
oh I mean oh yeah I mean it's oh this is
rated so and he just said pogchamp i
still don't know what that means but
normally when people talk to you in the
chat during a game you I usually don't
like to reply just because it takes your
attention away oh we could yeah we can
uncheck it yeah and just completely
ignore him so we should we should
continue to calculate Bishop e7 Bishop
f4 what if he if he plays queen c6 then
we have the BH square which I think is
is present in a lot of these lines like
Bishop f4 even if Queen b6 we have Queen
b8 so I sent out in an announcement
before about like 15 minutes before this
started oh I don't think he saw when he
played b5 I don't think he saw Bishop
take f7 coming I think he stumbled into
this where he kind of now has these
resources to trap the Queen and if this
were like a longer game if this were
like a 90 minute or two hour game and
it's very serious it's over the board
tournament I probably would have
calculated further just to make sure
when I win the rook
the Queen is safe that would have been
the more professional thing to do but in
a 10 minute online game sometimes you
have to rely on intuition and in this
case I relied on the fact that okay I
thought the Queen was okay I was winning
the rook I think it's turning out okay
one thing I forgot to identify he could
take on c2 but I think that's the least
of our worries right so he plays 97 he
wants to play knight c6 and completely
blocks out the Queen
he's also defending his bishop so if we
play Bishop f4 we can't we can't take on
c8
Bishop g5 is a candidate move but he
wants to play knight c6 in Bishop d7
these positions where the Queen is stuck
you always want to be aware of what the
opponent wants to do there's about four
but than a five the first move that
comes to mind here is a floor now he
might be able to play b4
I'm thinking a for a knight c6 we could
take and then oh he still has Bishop b7
this is not so easy that's also
interesting so f4 we don't have too much
time so we can't get caught up into any
of these variations a few six let's
double check and then Queen take f8
that's very possible
and if King g7 well that's it's very
messy but then maybe Bishop f4 at some
point Bishop g5 so so a lot of moves are
coming at me at once f4 f5 is probably
the thing I'll play if I don't find
anything better Bishop g5 knight c6 I I
don't see anything
oh you're saying Queens yet but night
would control d8 in this line so doesn't
quite work another idea is to play a
four knight c6 take if he plays Bishop
e7 we can take on b7 queen take b7 take
take and we have rook and minor piece
and the pawn I think for the Queen so
I'm going to throw in a four try and buy
some more time I'm gonna make him think
between knight c6 and playing b4 and
during this time I'll try and keep
calculating oh you're saying this should
be 7 right now Queenie
but the bishop hits us I did not see
this should be 7 right away but maybe we
still have Bishop f4 right sorry you
five and then Bishop to e5 it's original
resource right you want to play g3 and
then Bishop f4 ok well he plays knight
c6 which ok g3 is too slow yeah so
Bishop f4 now is possible but e 5 could
happen and then if we take you can take
with Knight Queen d5 King of 6 a 4 or a
b5 that's very possible but he could
play he could play d6 and then we could
take
yeah I think that line once the queen
escapes to d5 I think that's good so I
think we can throw in Bishop f4 yeah
okay we offer to rely on intuition we're
getting low on time but okay I'm pretty
sure okay this line should be come oh
wait a minute
Bishop d6 but we take on d7 on the check
right okay we might have to go over this
game later to identify all these crazy
sidelines he plays d6 so I can't take it
cuz he can take with Bishop I thinking
taking on b5 makes the most sense and
then or probably gonna have to sack the
Queen he's gonna play Bishop e7 and then
b6 but then Queen take b6 Wow
we could take on that fade as well
bishop take d6 could be a brilliant move
Bishop to d6 Queen take d6 and then
Queen take b7 and meanwhile his queen is
as attacked we're always happy to trade
Queens his Knight is still hanging
bishop g6 wait say that one more time
wait you're saying Bishop d6 Queen d7
buy can I can take on c6 and that would
be fine I mean the play Bishop to d6 I
think this is a really nice move was it
all for us from from Bishop take out
7000 from b5 rights
I know sometimes this is even a position
which the computer doesn't understand
because it can be it can be very
long-term or sometimes you turn on the
computer after b5 and it doesn't see the
Queen is getting trapped so I'm not sure
I have a feeling white should have
enough resources in these lines to save
the queen
but definitely going into this line I
think all of us underestimated how close
Black is to being better what if what
Queen b6 might keep the Queen trapped
but then York take a 6 right and can we
take b5 you should calculate Queen b6
and some some of you guys are quicker
than me trick 87 that's nice but then
there's some lines where black can win a
lot of material like take-take-take and
all the Sun black is up a minor piece
for three ponds and we could win d4 in
the end yes so I want to calculate this
line because it's interesting we said
Queen b6 rook take take if you just
joined us try and follow along rook a
seven pinning the bishop and then what
did we say when I take a seven Queen
take a seven Bishop take D 6 and then
Queen take d4 and hitting the rook and
hitting the bishop and then he would
play rook t eights
threatening bishop take H 2 maybe we
would play something like e 5 maybe
Queen III but then he can win B 2 so we
could keep going and going and going but
at some point you have to stop
calculations oh it might happen actually
so keep in mind we could always take on
b7 and kind of bail out which might be a
wiser option but I'm not sure
you said Queen take f3 o f8 trade
everything and then when I think would
be better to take on b7 and c6
take-take-take oh we're still attacking
the knight
that's very true actually
to take on FA to take
that's very true
okay we're going to take a poll between
Queen Sega fates rook take a six and
queen take d7 who votes for Queen take
f8 who votes for Luke take a six to
people who votes for Queens eighty-seven
still two people
okay we're play trick take a six can we
take a fate was probably a better
practical option but it was a vote I
think this is going to be the more
entertaining option but it is rated so -
no it's just leave Chester so it doesn't
matter we're not going to check the
check because we have to focus on the
game we can play this this is the only
move right
[Music]
and now we're going into this line we're
gonna have four pawns I believe for a
bishop I think he messed up when he
played b5 earlier but maybe he messed up
around here
Oh earlier on so we should keep in mind
there's a five-second increment so even
if we get really low on time we play
quickly enough we won't flag and we do
have to be ready for this line which is
probably about to happen I'm expecting
all of this tapping because it's all
very natural and I'm debating what to do
after rook c8 thinking just queen c3
maybe c4 would be an option there too
okay so he takes we take
we take to you for let's take an honest
poll how many people would prefer white
here how many people prefer black so
it's about split half and half I don't
know who's better here
there should be five don't say that too
loudly he might hear us I think that's a
good move
that was yeah unless he's like close by
that not aware of no I don't think he's
actually in here so he's winning upon
two bishops are very scary that's true
but we have we have some compensation we
have a lot of pawns for the peace and
his King is a lot less sheltered than
arts and we have a knight sometimes
Knights even though they're in many
cases less powerful than bishops there
lot trickier worth d8 we could defend
the pawn I was thinking we can just play
Knight here if he takes with the Queen
we have rook e1
and we should really focus on completing
development and we want to play Knight
c4 pressure the bishop defend the pawn
Knight a39 a3 may be similar in this
case we have options of playing Knight
f3 and maybe Knight g5 we also okay we
can't play this right away but we also
want to consider playing f4 someday I
for would be tragic to Bishop d4 and
maybe that's why he played rook to e8
trying to set up some cheapos I was also
thinking of ideas of Queen g5 attacking
the rook and pinning the bishop to the
Queen but that would be devastating at
Bishop take h2 but this is a good
situation he's thinking we have over two
and a half minutes which is a lot of
time compared to his time
and it's not clear what black should be
doing here so it might be that we have
some some time to optimize the pieces
I'm not playing I see four pretty
quickly just the most natural move he
attacks the Queen maybe we can hop into
h6 or g5 v g5 some of these moves I'm
just going to decide for myself I have
ideas of playing a five and ninety six
or Queen f6 it's going to allow us some
some nicer squares Queen e7 I don't
think we should trade Queens because
this King is less safe so Queen h6 is
one possibility Queen b5 another one
Queen a4 I'm gonna play Queen h6 attack
the pawn keep some initiative he defends
c3 is an option rook a one is an option
I don't quite like c3 because it weakens
d3 which he just can just move the
bishop and attack the D pawn I'm gonna
play King h1 it was kind of just a small
improving move okay he takes over the a
file not a bad move but I don't know
what his plan is
so f4 is an option I don't want to
create too many weaknesses immediately I
would like the position to remain a bit
static and try and get him lower in time
question is how to actually improve
maybe now we can play c3 because as rook
is no longer on d8 like c3 I'm gonna do
it
yeah here's Bishop g7 thinking then we
can retreat the Queen maybe even to h3
defending this pawn attacking pressuring
the c6 pawn uh-oh
just as I saw this should take f2 he
played Bishop take f2 that's unfortunate
because we can't take because of a crank
mates that was a very strong move the
bonus to this move is we now open a file
which could allow some more attack so
I'm thinking Knight e5 let's just go for
this na f3 could defend against mate I'm
thinking more aggressive Knight g4
because if his bishop ever moves and
Knight f6 could be a nice attacking move
he clearly wants to defend he also maybe
wants to trade Queens I want I would
like to play g3 but I'm not sure
guess Bishop g5 and then Queen h3 96 is
another option but this is where time is
becoming a lot more relevant I'm gonna
play g3 because it gets us out of back
rank mate and gives a rook a lot more
mobility and it has ideas of rook f7
where if he plays Bishop g5 then Queen
h3 and then we have threats of rook f7
very sharp position yeah he might shock
the Queen then it would be like the
Queen versus two bishops and a rook okay
this is gonna be a time scramble Bishop
f6 so we don't have work f7 we have this
move anything better
maybe Knight d7 is an option I'm just
gonna go for this
try and improve the night can consider
night h6 the setup is awkward for a
white I'm gonna play quick move Queen g2
it's an attempt to untangle the pieces
because I don't think the Queen was
doing too much on h3 maybe there is some
better option our King is still
relatively safe I might even play h3
King h2 someday h3 now makes a lot of
sense because it defends the Knights and
I'm probably against pushing pawns
because it opens up more lines for him
h5 is a very strong move I have to play
Knight h2 and then will reroute to f3
and he might try and kind of try yeah
like Queen Queen e3 how he might have to
trade Queens I didn't really want to do
but sometimes you have to do things you
want to do and we'll take with Knight
rook F 2 then Bishop takes c3 mmm
rook b1 is a move maybe Yorick be one
looks really passive though
does every move that's played we gained
five seconds okay he keeps attacking us
91 a scary position he keeps attacking
us just have to tell him to stop it he
wants to play Bishop g3 next which is a
big problem so I'm thinking about
ditching the G pawn and playing playing
this move it's not good
Oh Knight C 2 and this is definitely an
option I like that but he can he can
take here but then this wait a minute oh
this is bad this is really bad
forgot about g3 you should never make
random if you should always try and play
the best move possible but we're about
to lose I'm really sorry to say Knight
d1 you should never give up hope until
all hope is lost which is probably just
about now maybe c4 though passed pawns
must be pushed right am i giving you
guys heart attacks I'm sorry about that
okay there's some rules in chest you
should never resign when you have a
night because Knights are tricky except
he's about to meet us with this
okay we're gonna play mmm let's go here
okay so there's there's essentially one
way to potentially draw this position is
to create stale matrix I don't think
he's gonna fall for it but maybe he is
capable of it so we have to basically
give up the pawns get our King in the
stalemate position and force forcibly
sack the rook he'll probably made us
before then let's play trick here yeah I
think our King is in some sort of mating
net but maybe not
do you see mate bishop here here here
here I think we can run that's probably
a good move
let me do this wait a minute let's try
this that was another good move by him
and he's gonna play rook h2 next which
is so sad and then there's no way to
stop me we could check and he could take
it no he doesn't take it he could again
take it but he's he knows what's
happening I'm gonna resign and lose with
with sadness uh-huh
that was tough we thought we were gonna
win after like after what five moves and
then it was a matter I think there was a
really important moment in that game
which probably would have led to a win
if we had taken on that fate who wanted
to take on f8 in that position yeah good
choice going back there's a lot okay did
he say anything
yeah well played okay
so the great thing about B chess when
you play a game you haven't media access
to the analysis board and to this
opening explorer this position has
actually been reached before which I did
not know about sorry this is actual
chess so he played 94 which I'm
wondering is this some sort of opening
preparation I do want to show you guys
something that this reminded me off
because it's actually an opening that
I've studied before from the white side
let's turn off let's turn off the stock
fish an opening book for a moment I want
to show you this funny variation has
anyone seen this move before so when I
first saw this I thought it was a trout
for white where White's white and like
induces black to play a six plays Bishop
c4 induces lack to play b5
and then takes on f7 and I was under the
impression for maybe a year to two years
that this is uh this is just good for
white because queen h5 as we saw very
similarly what happened in our game
light ones are oak what I learned not
too long ago is the Queen gets trapped
in this position very easily and
actually if you check the statistics
black wins the majority of the games and
actually I think if you leave the engine
running for long enough just show you
guys a stock fish will stock fish will
eventually say black is better stock
fish is just refusing to do anything
right now it will start saying whites
better because it's counting material it
sees whites up the exchange but maybe
you'll just have to trust me or you'll
have to dig deeper that black is better
in this position I wonder if this has
happened in the Masters database no so
going back to this game I think this is
sorry oh it's a net I I wonder how
deeply it's calculating this has been
played before and each sb5 has been
played close to 850 times and only 86
people were smart enough or maybe not
smart enough to to take on f7 but white
scores well here and it's always nice
when you have like a lot of games to see
kind of what happened
I think our mistake in this game my
mistake especially was under estimating
position but and even that the engine is
saying black is better here which is
incredible which actually means if you
play the Russell emo this is probably
aligned to at least know about so I feel
like even strong players could walk into
this sorry
I wonder if he was prepared it's
possible but he spent some time on
playing b5 so maybe he wasn't I don't
know I'll have to ask him well we'll ask
him afterwards so okay we do have like
the the computer automatically analyze
this and apparently knight c6 was not
the best move yeah I was thinking he
would play d4 here and then the game
could continue along the lines of
someone mentioned I think Arjun you
mentioned f4 f5 which would have been
which would have been interesting
sometimes the engine can spit out an
evaluation and then from a human
standpoint it's it can be a different
story of of which side has kind of the
easier play but yeah going forward in
this game we're gonna turn off engine
just so we don't get lazy and I do want
to show what probably I should have
listened to from this position queen
take f8 I think was the superior move
was after take take take take Black has
no time to take on b2 Bishop takes c6
and b3 and yeah White's
white should be easily winning in this
position two rooks but goes to show like
sometimes even though we saw this or
maybe saw this possibility in the heat
of the game it's hard to make like the
most accurate decision and only in
hindsight do you realize how simple it
could have been so interesting game that
was fun I think we'll have time for at
least one more so hopefully we get the
black side and then you guys will have
to fight which opening we play between
French and what was other line did
anyone suggest Oh Queens gambit declined
oh so that may be that will be easier
we'll play okay he wants another game
let's play someone different though
we could play a tournament we're gonna
go to the lobby and just find finding
someone seeking a game let's play this
guy I'm sure he'll be but is he still
there
yeah I'll be surprised to be playing oh
we're white again let's play Kali you're
gonna have to tell me what the Kali is
because it's is it III or Knight f3 III
okay as far as I know you you play
something like this right
no oh you gopher but he's playing Bishop
at five
like Bishop that's what you usually do I
want to introduce you to a new idea when
they play Bishop at 5:00 which which is
c4 it's very common especially in Queens
pawn openings if they move their Bishop
out early you want to play c4 and Queen
b3 so even though this started as a
Colley for the first two moves we're
going into a line which I think offers
white better chances and hopefully
you'll see why oh he takes which maybe
isn't the best move we can just take
with Bishop at the very least blacks
should usually wait until we develop our
bishop to take on c4 just so we would
lose a tempo but okay we already we
might have tactics does anyone see any
tactics here yeah
Queen b3 also have Queen f3 there's
there's several targets in this position
between the bishop queen h5 could be met
with Bishop g6
so I think it's a debate between these
two moves
yeah but that will win upon ya
but from the previous game we have to be
a bit careful that if we think we're
trapping him we were not getting my
counter trapped
I think queen bee 3 should be yeah I was
just very simple though we're gonna take
a pawn
we're threatening me than one so
hopefully he defends this pawn right
like Bishop b4 would be a nice move
Bishop afford defending and attacking
and neglecting mates I'm expecting a six
or a Bishop g6 probably e6 and black
will attempt to get compensation because
we're spending a lot of moves with the
Queen to win the pot and then he's gonna
develop maybe slightly quicker but
upon's upon
well he's under he's being attacked and
he's scared so we'll take the pawn he
plays rook PA he's giving us another
pawn I didn't who would take the pawn if
he plays rook b8 everyone would take the
pawn two pawns are two pawns yeah but
yeah we should keep developing here he's
actually he's threatening to do this so
Knight f3 is maybe a playable move
I like Knight c3 though also there's
many times especially in situations like
this where we have two Center pawns we
would like to advance
efore he just swung a bishop the
backwards attacking of it's one of the
most overlooked moves in chess really a
chess life column I'm backwards
attacking moves yeah for some reason I
think backwards Knight moves are the
most overlooked moves he left the game
no we're not gonna play all trouble at
least not the next maybe the last game
will say let's play a 5/5 game let's
play jdd black he's rated just under
1,800 5 5 is 5 minutes plus 5 second
increments let's play French people want
the French I've played the French a
total of 2 times my whole life in
tournament play I have an OK score with
it he's playing Knight c3 so we'll play
d5 exchange variation
well it's not dubious if like its
dubious if white plays b3 d4 is
certainly the most appealing option and
then the knight can be moved because
this is a faster time control I'm going
to rely on intuition and play d4 so I
think this should be this should be fun
for black for getting a lot of time
you've had this before really I
okay so d3 is attractive but it might be
overextending c5 a move
so of course you will always want to be
on the lookout for traps
I just want to develop I'm gonna play
Knight f6 which maybe isn't the most
exciting move but I see that the e-file
is open and that okay we're gonna play
Bishop c5 because I want a castle and
gather rook to e8 before he has time to
get his King castled and this is just a
like thematic positional play so he
really wants to win the pawn I would I
would consider sacking the pond I'm also
considering just castling or Bishop g4
looks really attractive but Bishop g4 it
gets tactical after this take and then
Bishop take if we take on e2 he takes
with check so knight c6 is a the most
natural move to play without too much
thoughts except that required some
thoughts okay we still want to castle h3
is a good sign he's scared that Bishop
g4 but he's slowing down his development
so we'll castle and get the rope to
Yates and yeah we're a slightly famous
here for spectators but rookie eights is
going to be very annoying for him Knight
e4 potentially I was thinking yeah 94 in
d3 and trying made him on f2 now he
might play d3 himself at some points but
that could be weakening to the dark
squares
wow he's playing very slow with a three
so rook e8 I'm still looking for better
options like 94 immediately with the
threat of d3 by like rook e8 because now
this Knight is stuck and because I might
have stuck the bishop is stuck and
because a bishop is stuck the King is
stuck so he's expanding on the Kings
side he wants to win the pawn I guess
there's Knights pain there's actually
some smother mating potential in some
lines which I'm trying to figure out how
it could potentially work like for
example here take we take on d4 and were
threatening 93 mates but we don't want
to give away a piece just to hope for
mates so Bishop d6 makes a lot of sense
there should be six b5 and then then
maybe I was thinking d3 immediately
disturbed the pawns okay I'm gonna start
with Bishop b6 it's probably going to
play b5 and then I'll have to think
now this should still be good for black
even if he wins this fun but we could
play 95 the pawns probably not lost oh I
see a cool line okay I'm gonna play 95
if he takes a pawn
take-take-take we sack the Queen and we
have double checkmate 19th there's a sea
pawn but there there would have been
like some double checkmating potential I
have to show that afterwards double
checkmate is where you attack the King
twice and it's meat it's like double
check mate right so he's still stuck
like Knight of stock Bishop a stock King
is stuck I think the idea here is to
just triple up and complete development
guys focus for a long time it still
takes work to win this position we
haven't won like a full game yet we won
that previous game but that that didn't
feel satisfying you see a trap what's
your trap
naive or hoping for this I don't know
that's a trap I just hope chess if this
were a bug house we would play Knight f3
mates Queen d5 looks really funny in her
Queen g5 attacking the rook and he was
not going to Castle no cuz he can't the
only way for him to defend the rook is
to move the rook so what to play after
rook g1 or rook h2 so now he wants to
play Bishop g2
so you're saying 94 I'm still gonna play
Bishop g2 you want to play d3 that looks
nice
and we sack the rook let me take on f2
we could play d3 first and then we know
d3 would lose the rook still we don't
want to go too crazy here it's one thing
to try and avoid we could also just take
the b-pawn that's a really good point I
mean yeah I'm gonna take the beef on
because we attack the bishop as bishops
just about stuck and we keep the
pressure on the Knights and maybe we'll
buy ourselves enough time to execute
some maneuver though okay now he wants
to take you said Knight d5 oh I see what
you mean that feels like hope chess
really feels like hope Jessica so he
could play so you're saying this this
Knight g5 he could play Bishop g2 oh
then we take and then we win the rook
and we straight Queens and we win the
bishop in the end - I like that
that's me and the amazing thing is like
you can't really he can't really defend
the square other than playing yeah if he
plays Oh check me oh okay
that was nice I don't think he had too
many other options we gained two points
nice job guys
I lost a lot of points for the previous
game though I don't think I want to
check that but okay so Debra and follow
that line Bishop g2 just to show people
who might have a hard time visualizing
take take take this was the whole
calculation where black would be up a
bishop and a knight in this position
yeah we have some some fans in the chat
one thing I wanted to show you guys when
when what was playing I think was it
before yeah so when this was played an
idea with B 595 I was really hoping for
this line where it looks like he can win
the pawn with with capturing and the
move for black in this position
viewers at home if you want to pause
your video and find the move for black
really nice move Queens 84 because if
Knight take we have our option actually
have an option of double checkmates
Knight f3
ya don't see this every day to sack the
Queen double mate so do we have time for
one more game do you guys want to end it
here or we could play like one of those
crazy like bullet games I don't think I
can take too many recommendations 1/2
plus 0 so half plus 0 is 30 seconds no
increments
that would be too fast we can also play
15-second chess so the the half minute
one went away but we still have 15
second chests so I think we're gonna end
with this if there's any young people
watching which is most of you you should
close your eyes right now
but actually hopefully okay he's here
try not to recommend moves but if you
feel the urge guess you can it's all
about getting a time advantage and maybe
meeting him yes okay that was fun
this is this is sometimes a trick in
this type of chess is to uh Louise a
good game good game is to go for cheap
tricks and hope they're moving too fast
so I think we're gonna end it there
because Ben Simon just walked in no
that's that was a good finish I hope so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this I was
hoping to call the title of this video
crushing people on HS org but because we
got crushed in the first game I have to
figure out another title so that will be
Ben's job so yeah have a good night guys
and take care
[Music]